ELECTION EMBSS
N?
ESSIGNE  AGAIN."
AU THERE'S A ELOO'RE SEEING FOR.
THE ST 202ID THE
ERC SECHT OLST
ERRORRSANTHPOLLS
RS AT LEAST TWO DECADES LD
DESOASWHY.
CLINN.N D DOWNEMOCRATS
ARE MAKINGAI IN THAND FOUND THA
AR PE POES. BIDEN IND MRS.NTON .
HE FURTHER NOTES THAT S , ITL B
CYNOTHE LASTHANGES T
IN CTES WHERE CH HASDEMOCRATS FU
MY NEXT GUA TRACK RECORDHOWING A
POLLS
POLLIN 2016 THEY CORRECTLY HMP
BETO
SWING ESPENNSYLVANIA,
PREDICTENAL  FLORI ANOH EL
THE GOE ANCK. MNOW.R DeSANTI
SO IE LI
INTO SUCH A
DIM ON
Y
WHAT WE SA6  KIND OF ASHY REPUBC
PEOP WE HESITANT TO ADMI
WE HADICLES TO ND THAT INL SHYN
TO WHE THEY COULD PRAND
E R INSTEAD OFANSWER.
TNT TO PAIC POLLS.K EXTR.
THANO  T 2020 TENDEDBEALP, NUMP
SUBMERGED VOTERSE ARS THATREHAI.
AVE SEEN WHAT BEEN SEEING ABOUGH
ERT'R NOT,T OF THE CONACF OUNG .
THEY'RE NOT PUTTING STICKERS ON
THEIT PUTTINGNS IN
, NOING POLLS
IT'S LIKE THEY'RE
TO BE VERYT COMING UP UNTIND THE
FIC.
IN I KNOW WE HERE
IN PENNSYLVANIA, THE WHOLE
COUNTRY IS FOCMA
,  SHAPIRO AND
MAANO.
EA BOTH OF TES.R EXAMPLE,M ISHAI
OZ BY  SHAPIO BY
CBS AND AY
SHO
D T YOU SAE IS
TWO-PO
JUSTIFY THAT
TIGHTEN AND WEE ON THE SIZE N, I
THAT'SECOGZIT WI EDIBLE GROUP E
YOU HAVE TO GO FIND --SMEN HK HS
Y TRYINGRGEDECE REPUBLICANS AREE
CURRENCYS YOUR REPUTENDYAYS,S IO
S GOINE
A DA WL HT?TO BE
UY WHO CALLED IT RIGHT
DIDN'T.
>>RIGHT.E FIL WO
I ALWAYS JOKE THEY MAY SAY WE'R
DODERSTA